[Music]
hey everyone good evening welcome to
today's question python let's wait for a
few seconds for others to join
some more time
[Music]
hey everyone
very very funny
increasing in numbers we are 18 live now
we'll start that quiz very soon and in
the meanwhile
i will give you an insightful for you
guys
like if you guys are focused on building
strong foundational skills for character
in that case you can check out a free
course to learn python basics for the
completion certificate from skill up
bicycle
you can check the python basics free
scale up course link in the description
box below
till then you guys can check it
and we'll wait for some few seconds
for more people to join
now
more people coming up
guys we have excited
today
top three scorers so the top three
leaderboard persons will get everyone
wants us
just a few more seconds
to start the quiz
we're just waiting for few more people
to just get around with us
any science
i think it's your favorite topic
so
[Music]
okay guys
let's start on today's quiz
and before we start we will take a small
recap into the world of python so hello
everyone and thanks for joining us
so let's take a quick look at what
python programming language is its
features its application and some
popular id so python programming
and be sure to stick around till the end
of the quiz for a chance to win amazon
vouchers
if you become on one of the top 3
winners
so let's start with python
today python is used by many big giants
intel ibm nasa pixar netflix facebook jp
morgan
spotify and a number of other companies
it's one of the four main languages i
took
while the platform you are currently
using that's google youtube is largely
written in python
same with reddit pinterest and instagram
now we'll see what really python is
python is a strong high-level
object-oriented programming language
there are two popular python versions
python 2 and python 3 with an upgrade
python 2 and python 3 are pretty
different today python 3 is mostly used
because it is more popular and supports
various new functions
in the previous python versions that is
up to python 2.7.0 the print command was
not written in parenthesis
python was developed by guido and busan
in 1989 and was released in 1991.
python gives preference to indentation
for blocks instead of curly braces the
standard indentation recommends python
code to use four spaces
standard python code supports both tabs
and spaces the name python was taken
from the popular bbc comedy show of that
time that was monty python's flying
circus
there's an interesting fact about python
a man named tim peters composed a poem
called the zen of python about python
programming
simply type import this into an
interpreter to read this poetry
python programming has grown its
popularity on people of all ages and
industries it has become the language of
choice story
now let's move to the features of python
the first feature is open source
python is an open source and free
programming language which means that
source code is freely available to the
general public at no most the next
feature is easy to port being a
high-level programming language with a
considerably less index it becomes very
easy to port large projects in python
the next feature we have is
object-oriented programming
python supports all the paradigms
includes making it highly relevant in
the modern world the next is interpreted
language python code is executed line by
nine during compilation so it's an
interpreted name
the next feature is dynamically typed
in python the data type of a variable is
determined dynamically at runtime
this feature is called being dynamically
typed
the next is integrated language python
is an integrated language because we can
easily integrate it with c c plus plus
and many other languages
the next feature is the high level
language python is a high level language
we don't need to manage memory or system
architecture to code in it the next we
have is portable in nature being
portable we can run the same python port
on any platform with windows mac linux
etc
the next we will see the applications of
python
the first is desktop applications
the desktop applications are very
popular with python
the python provides the peak
interlibrary that can be used to develop
user interfaces you can start with
creating simple applications such as
calculators
apps and much more complex applications
the next we have is web development
python can be used to make web
applications at a rapid rate it is
because of the frameworks python uses to
create these applications
and guys the code is at the top of the
screen you can see that and the link is
www.menti.com
and just go to the website and enter the
port that is 6337.9985
and we will continue with that
the next application is data science
data is money
if you know how to express relevant
information which can help you take
calculated risks and increase profits
you study your data perform operations
and extract the required information
libraries such as pandas and numpy help
you in extracting information you can
even visualize the data libraries such
as matplotlib and cbone which help load
graphs and much more this is what python
offers you to become a data scientist
the next application we have is game
development
python is also used in the development
of interactive games there are libraries
such as pysoid a 3d game engine
supporting python 3 and pygame which
provides functionality and a library for
game development games such as
civilization for business downtown
online vegas strike etc have been built
using python
the next we have is machine learning and
artificial intelligence machine learning
and artificial intelligence are the
talks of the town as they yield the most
promising careers for the future we make
the computer learn based on past
experiences through the data store or
better yet create algorithms that make
the computer learn by itself the
programming language that mostly
everyone chooses it's python because it
supports these domains with existing
libraries such as pandas skillet learn
numpy and many more
learn the algorithm use the library and
you have your solution to the program it
is that simple but suppose you want to
go the hardcore way in that case you can
design your own board which yields a
better solution it is still much easier
when we compare it to other languages
now moving on we will see some popular
idealist used by python programmers
first is visual studio port
i personally use it the next is pie
charm the next is spider notebook
sublime text
and jupyter note
now guys we have 46 folks with us
you can start the quiz or just we can
wait for
some few seconds
and yeah
yeah guys the code is at the top and the
link is also at the top you can visit
the link and enter the port
and just wait for the quiz to start
so like it's highly recommended if you
use two devices for convenience one
could be your mobile phone and the other
a laptop or another mobile phone so to
participate in the quiz you can visit
the website from one device that is
www.menti.com and use the code mentioned
you can also use a different tab on the
browser to take part in the quiz and we
will broadcast the correct answers and
results in the live stream as soon as
the participants mark their answer so
it's beneficial to have both invisible
simultaneously once you open the link
and fill in the code wait for the quiz
to start and be ready to answer the
questions and the rules are very simple
the quicker you answer the more points
you get so be sure to think fast and
click faster
viewers please join the link
now we'll be getting start with the quiz
just 10 seconds and we'll start with the
quiz so please join the link
ready for the quilts
ready to win the amazon vouchers
51 folks have joined us
i think google already
so let's start guys
we are starting with the quiz if anyone
is left to join please don't fast
okay guys the instruction is answer
so the first question is what is the
correct file extension for python source
file your options are
and be good guys
extension for python source files
20 seconds left
be good guys
so everyone has voted and only 18
persons are in the quiz
guys join the link
that is
www.menti.com and the code is 637-9985
and 18 people have
corrected
the correct answer that is stored by
extension
very well guys
and in the leaderboard we have she said
on the top
so that is the dot d y dot p y c dot b y
pyo android pyd files have their own
significance when it comes to executing
python programs they are used for like
dot py it's the input source code that
you have written your pyc the compiled
byte book if you import a module python
fill builder dot pyc file that contains
the python to make importing it again
later easier
in the dot pyo file it was created while
optimizations
pyd file it's a windows dll file for
python
so guys get ready for the next question
we'll be moving on to the next question
and be quick
so the question is how do you insert
commands in python port
and no options are you got four options
just pick the correct one
and be the first on the leaderboard
i think you have plenty of time for this
question to one left with 21 seconds
so how inside comments in python just
take the correct answer
it's three two one come on guys time's
up
we have 17 people who have
marked the correct answer that is hash
and after that you can write your
statement
that's the how comments are done
so comment in python starts with the
hash character and extends to the end of
the physical line commands can be used
to make the code more readable commands
can be used to prevent execution when
testing code right multi-line commands
close the text between the triple ports
it's for the single line and for multi
lines you can use triple quotes
okay guys now moving on to the
leaderboard
so four has stopped the leaderboard and
then we have pushed [ __ ] and my
so
get remembered the first three
winners would get the amazon vouchers so
be quick
now move to the next question
be ready guys
which of the following cannot be a
python variable name and your options
are
be quick guys it's a very basic question
how do we write the variable names in
python
means almost the same in every language
let's be quick
we have 17 seconds left
time's up guys
so 21 have marked it correct that is abc
hyphen 2 very well guys we don't use
hyphen in writing the variable names a
variable can have a short name like x
and y or more descriptive names like age
star name and total underscore
let's revise the rules the first rule is
a variable name must start with the
letter or the underscore character it's
satisfied
second is a variable name cannot start
with a number no option is starting with
a variable number in our options the
third is a variable name can only
contain alphanumeric characters and
underscores but here we have hyphen so
this is the option that is not correct
writing the variable name the next two
is variable names are case sensitive
so you can write age in uppercase
lowercase in any cases so all are
accepted now moving on to the
leaderboard
let's see what has changed
i'll show it is still at the top the
second position is scored by four and
then the my row
pass it to the fastest
okay moving on to the next question guys
be ready
so how do you create a variable name
with the numeric value 7 and your
options are
on the screen
because this is also a very easy
question
you should get it right
and guys don't answer in the chat box
you can join the quiz and answer there
you have the chance to build amazon
watchers
and be on the top of the leaderboard
guys
has 16 seconds left
answer it quickly
guys and it's times up
the correct option is c both a and b 11
people were correct with the answer
as you can see variables are containers
for storing data values python has no
command for declaring a variable a
variable is created the moment to first
assign a value second option is if you
want to specify the data type of a
variable this can be done with casting
so both a and b are correct
that is c option that holds both a and b
that is correct
moving on to the leaderboard
let's see
what has changed okay first it is
fastest till now four and my row
okay they are just fed the top three
positions they're not letting anyone
just come their way
okay one more to the next question that
is the fifth question
which of the following is true about
local variables
any question guys
you can see there's a local variable x
here
you can also judge from that
four options just tell out the local
variables if you won't see the code you
can answer that also
thanks for still answering in the
comment section so please be on the link
and join the link
if you're missing something guys
and time's up guys
so the correct answer is marked by 12
persons that is accessible only in that
function
so if you declare a variable in a block
it is local to that block or function
and cannot be used outside of the block
or function in which it is declared it
can also open in a for statement a
switch statement and many mores
so it should be in the top for local
value
now let's see the leaderboard is anyone
brought up
those three are just maintaining the
positions
okay
sixth question that is which of the
following is our features of
dictionaries
so
the collection
and one of those is dictionaries and you
have got four options just mark
there is a feature which likes
stability dynamic
allow the ticket keys and values for all
of the work
participate
in change anytime you would be on the
top of the leaderboard
there only fours are correct
okay guys
okay
okay default
let's see who
has supported right
dragonite
still at the top
okay guys so how it's dynamic
dictionaries are used to store data
values in events a dictionary is a
collection which is ordered
and it has a strict mark like it's
ordered in some extent
it's changeable meaning that you can
change add or remove items after the
dictionary has been created that is
dynamic and it does not allow duplicates
the values and dictionary items can be
of any data type as a python version 3.7
dictionaries are ordered in python 3.6
and earlier dictionaries are unknown
so we have the correct option that is be
dynamic
moving on guys
just be ready with the sound question
and be quick to answer that
what would be the data type of the bad
in the below port snippet
you have 33 seconds
make it
10
we do one time sub dice
so everyone has voted and 14 good attack
that is string and end
so guys uh to get the type of variable
in platform you can choose the building
type thousand
initially that stores simply learn and
so is of type string and that it stores
10 which is of type and variables do not
need to be declared with any particular
type and can even change
type after they have been set what we
see in the above sniper so the correct
option is e string and end
congratulations guys who's who impacted
and need a whole
so he was the fastest
very well going on to the next question
that is eighth question
that is what will be the output of the
following code separate
you can see the picture
on the screen
be quick guys we have 40 seconds for
that
you have four options
floating in total float
intended
you have
a good chance with what option can
manipulate it
it's p21 time's up guys
and 17 people have marked the correct
answer that is float and end
very well guys
the first expression that was performing
standard division so the result is
stored as a float type and the second
expression that was performing integer
division so the result is stored as n
type
that was 11 divided by 2 the first
here we'll give the output as 5.5 and
the second will give up two times five
that is flopping
so very well guys now see the
leaderboard
okay there is
so support voted
incorrect and parachute myofor they're
still at the top positions
followed by the dragonite
very well guys now let's be ready for
the ninth question
the question is what is the output of
the four line program
and the program is on the screen
it's very easy
to find function
just remember the functioning of the
time function and you will get the
correct answer
23 7 slap guys
you can see that
so time's up guys
the correct answer is 7 and it has been
marked by 13 folks
the fine method
so what does the find method does guys
the find method finds the first advance
of the specified value that was
specified in the parenthesis that was ea
the find method returns -1 if the value
is not found here fine has found ea at
seventh position and return the position
it returns a position
it would have written minus one if the
substring doesn't exist inside the frame
so very well guys you have to put it
correct
over to the leaderboard
let's see
first it may report dragonite
okay so dragonite is following the three
musketeers
okay
now moving to the next question
that is 10
what is the output of the following
program and you would see the code on
the screen
it removes the ord function
and you will get 35 seconds for that
guys
just remember the function of order
great number with us that is 92 and are
you guys the part of the base i think
many are not so please join the quiz
guys
can get ready for the next week you can
see the platform how it is and you can
win the next of this in the next phase
so 16 people wrote it right
very well
so the question was
print o d t minus o id b
so the oid function returns the number
representing the unicode for specified
character this function accepts a string
of unit length as an argument and
returns the uniform equivalence of the
past argument
here the unicode of t minus p that was
100 minus 98 that was two
and 16 people got it right very well
guys
moving on to the leaderboard
so he has some changes
with the parts it's time for the knight
is the fastest
very good
so let me go to the next question that
is the 11th question
what is the output of the following
program and the
program will be displayed on the screen
here's a list and we are just printing
the list with an argument
just
check with their tags
something very interesting almost like a
list so if you are going through it and
easy about what it answer
and the time sub guys
and the 19 people have marked it correct
very well guys
four dragonite
very well
so it was easy question survive
so
the negative indexing that was the
negative indexing that starts from where
the area ends this means that the last
element of the array is the first
element in the negative indexing which
is minus one here we have 15 as the
first element from last
so moving on to the data board guys
and just quick reminder
the top three scorers can send your
screenshots after the presents to
youtube contest at the simplylearn.net
to receive your amazon numbers so don't
forget to do that
we have the next question that is 12th
question
what will be the output produced by the
following program
and the will be displayed on the screen
guys this is also
the question of list
so i hope you guys can understand the
options display there
what this contains 2693 1029 so at that
only in the options
that is in the spare packets
seven seconds everyone has noted okay
17 people got it right very well guys
so i think today you are getting some
easy questions so you are just foreign
so without it sorry
so my robot in practice time
okay i should hold my loop we are still
at the top positions
tests are one of the four built-in data
types in python that is used for
collections of data
the other three types are double set and
extend
all with different qualities
lists are created using sphere brackets
as we can see here and the operator we
have used is the s trigger
that responds to the
strings
this means it repetitions the string or
the elements in the list
so it has multiplied it by two and just
given the output
moving on to the next question guys
which of these collections defines a
tuple
a very very easy question
you can just get it
by
minor claims of the options
it could be a quick
i hope you all will
get it correct
so
those who are commenting in the chat
books please join the quiz guys
20 people put it correct very well
there's some shopping in the top three
positions and dragonite is not far
behind guys
make it up tonight
and here we were talking about the
tuples doubles are written with round
brackets they are used to sort multiple
items in a single variable
double is one of the four built-in data
types in python that is used to store
collections of data moreover a tuple is
a collection which is ordered and
unchangeable and you want to try to
choose the round bracket software very
well guys we go to the next question
that is 14 questions and you would find
the options
little bit like
what i found in the previous question so
just
be aware with your eyes okay
the next question is what is the output
of the following snippet the code is in
front of you
question is very easy just be careful
with the options
you just have to understand you just
need one second
and just give a sight to these objects
everyone guys 11 seconds are left be
quick
it's the easy one
everyone has voted
okay there could be a major suffering in
the leaderboard first you'll see that
okay moving on the explanation guys the
greatest have used to perform operations
on values and variables these are the
special symbols that carry out
arithmetic logical bitwise computations
the value the operator operates on is is
known as operand because both x and y
refer to the same object here the x and
y they refer to the same object when we
use edition assignment that is plus
equal to operator on y it changes both x
and y
and
the sign add right like what
does this operator do it add right side
of brand with left side open and then
assign to leftover
so very well guys who knows just open
and they put it correct
moving on to the next question that is
routine
which of the following data types equal
to equal to greater cannot be applied
that is like quality operator guys
that's a very easy question
you just have to be
good with the basics you can easily
answer that
quality operator from which of these
collections is not applicable
eleven seconds left guys and i think one
of the answers
you can see the link on the top of the
screen that is 42w dot menti
just type in on the search bar you will
get to the website and they would get
the blank box just type the code there
that is 3 6 3 3 7 9 8 9
we'll start with the quiz
okay 13 people quoted correct that is
none of the above valuable guys
like it was a tricky one but it was the
basic motion
so let's see what has changed in the
data board
dragon knight
four [ __ ] okay these are maintaining
network repositions
very well guys
now see like uh what
why it's
applicable in all roles the quality of
beta is a comparison operator in python
that compares values of both the
operands and checks for value quality
and is applied to all the three
mentioned
so it's applicable to all the books
moving on to the next question that is
16th question guys
to the following operators cannot be
applied to dictionaries
be careful
that
you can see which operators are not
applicable to this
didn't join the quest or are you facing
any more inputs
type in the chat section
okay guys eight seconds left
and we put it right
19 people got it from both cnc very well
guys
let's see the stuffing in the
leaderboard
i don't get about this
i just popped it
now let's see uh
why both these operators are applicable
so dictionaries are used to show data
values in key value pairs a dictionary
is a collection which is changeable it
does not allow duplicates and doesn't
have any elements in a definite order
they are similar to sets
and the concept of subset and superset
is not applicable in dictionaries the
subset and superset operators are
meaningless in dictionaries
so
it doesn't accept them
that's the basic point guys moving on to
the next question that is 17 questions
be ready and be quick
so we have which of the following is an
operator that works only on one operand
you will get four options be quick with
that
operator that works only on one operand
see
it's
just above the basic question
and mark the correct option
few seconds left everyone has voted very
well okay 21 people have answered it
back
it's very good
so you have that basic for the knowledge
so it's the note operator and here's the
leaderboard
for made it quick
i said dragonite very well
the persons below the leaderboard they
are just shuffling
oh very well
let's get to the explanation
the unary operators require only one
operand they perform various operations
such as incrementing decrementing a
value by one negating an expression or
inverting the value of a boolean
python's not operator that is the first
option you have choose it correctly
allows you to invert the truth value of
boolean expression and objects you can
use this operator in boolean context
such as if statements and while loops it
also works in non-boolean context which
allows you to invert the truth value of
your variables
very well you guys should have that
moving on to the next question that is
18th
what is the output phoning snippet
you have that port in front of you guys
week with 35 seconds
in your timer
and so far to get more points guys
so here it's just stopping the
leaderboard
make something change
and then it's in the load function
with the forward
and the time sub guys
okay 15 people
said it correctly and 13 people got it
wrong
it simply opened okay
so guys it returns uh in the list
context and in the inverted commerce
so so see the leaderboard
four heads are fragment and in the
bottom
very well
so the lower method returns a string
where all characters are lowering
symbols and numbers are ignored
load method doesn't take any parameters
if no uppercase characters exist it
returns the original string here it has
returned the lowercase of simple
moving on to the next question
that is 19 questions be quick with it
and it's what will be the output of the
following code snippet and the code is
in front of you
hey we've used the slicing
if you are familiar with the concept you
can answer it very quickly
then we have pen command also you can
see that the joining board is mentioned
here
and those of you guys have no join me
join
if you want to participate in more
business by simply not and you can win
the amazon vouchers and more exciting
fighters and times up for the quiz guys
for the particular question
and 12 people reported correct the
option is b february march
first one separately
hey guys i want
you guys to just make the leaderboard
shuffle
those three guys have maintained the top
three positions
okay moving on to the explanation
similar to negative indexing python also
supports negative slicing this means you
can start slicing from the end of the
sequence
this is an example of slicing with
negative indexes in the list here the
slicing starts at the index -3 which is
the third last element of the list the
slicing ends at the last item which is
at the index minus one
very good guys
move on to the next question
let's
what will be the result of the following
expression in python and the expression
is in front of you here we have used
some operations
that is exponential
definition
with it guys you just have to do a
calculation if you know the functioning
of this exponential operator
get it correct
i think the quiz is very interesting
we're getting the simplest quotes and
the most interesting ones
thanks up guys
sitting people put it correct
let's see the shuffling in the
leaderboard
with fast test sorry something about 856
and the network is faster sorry
so before i shoot regularly
the top three positions
and moving on to the explanation so
arithmetic operators are used with
numeric values to perform common
mathematical operations here we are
using exponentiation operator
though
about expression that would be available
like that would be evaluated
i'm seeing the expression that is p
exponential 3 plus 6 exponential 2
that would result to 27 plus 36 that
would be 63
so very well guys those who got it
correct
moving on to the next question that is
21
which of the following is not a feature
of a tuple
you will put four options
mark the correct one
an easy one
couple is one of the four collections
you can just remember its properties
and
the point which is not a picture of
trouble
19 seconds in your pocket
make it quick guys
and people are also answering in the
chat books very well guys
hopefully you could help the persons who
are just visiting this space after while
update button
so we can join the link guys
so six people put it correct
okay go fix it
so moving on to the leaderboard
we can see four dragonite and pastry
topping the leaderboard and
foreign with round brackets they are
used to store multiple items in a single
variable
is one of the four built-in data types
in python that is used to store
collections of data moreover a tuple is
a collection which is ordered and
unchangeable and allow duplicate values
that is its feature and mark which is
not its feature that is does not allow
the ticket values
so
just the confusing way
moving on to the next question
each of the following deletes the second
key value pair in the following
dictionary and you have the dictionary
stored in the tick variable dic variable
and you put the four options
you just have to choose the methods
which can delete the second key value
with just some methods
in our second lab with you guys
it's also the easy one
we just know the functioning of the
functions
time's up guys
okay nine people voted correct
and
13 people have gone with that
yeah
it's correct and we have one more option
that's correct that is b option that is
support
let's see the leaderboard
fastest
now moving on to the explanation guys
dictionaries are used to store data
values in key value pairs as you all
know a dictionary is a collection which
is ordered with a strict mark
changeable and do not allow duplicates
to delete a particular key value pair we
can use both the functions that is
delete dot dic
and in the square brackets you can just
write the argument
or pass it the key value where you want
to delete it the next option is take
your pop and you can pass in the square
brackets sorry uh the round brackets set
the practice
going on to the next question that is 25
question
so what will be the output of the
following snippet the sniper is in front
of you
you have set one in set two and we're
printing the length
it's
also a bit
easy confusing question
after 30 seconds
think it wisely
and accept it quickly
okay guys 14 seconds left be quick with
it
an easy question
about the sets one of the four
collections
three two one
and time's up
okay
eight people quoted correct and 25 and
born with this the option that is six
yeah it's a little bit confusing
so let's see the leaderboard
which guys have made it to the top
so
these three guys are still maintaining
that top three positions and in the
previous phases they were shuffling in
the top frequencies in the last
reference
and we are at the 23rd version
okay
so getting on to the explanation guys
sets are used to store multiple items in
a single variable a set is a collection
which is unordered unchangeable and
unindexed the board will give an error
since plus operator is more downloaded
for sets in python
so that's why it will give an error
moving on to the next question
that easy one
does not contain duplicates you will get
four options
three is collection and the fourth one
is all of them
guys
get it correct
so are you guys enjoying the quest
please answer it in the chat section
after we have attempted the question
and you have any suggestions please
interrupt it in the chat
i will show that 10 times up guys
19 people have done it correct
that is set
very good that was the easy question i
was expecting that
my room
give it the first test
for
okay
going with the explanation guys
so set is one of the four building data
types in python that is used to store
collections of data set items are
unordered unchangeable and do not allow
duplicate values
moving on to the last question of the
quiz
be quick with
so the question is what will be the
output of the following code snippet
35 seconds you have to make it quick
if you're confused with the options i
will go through it it's 12 23 minus 13
13.3 the second is 13 24 minus 13 13.
there would be four answers in four
seals
facts
12 seconds in the pocket be fast
these were the basic functions you could
put the functionality right you would
answer it very quickly
move on to the leaderboard that would be
our final winners
that's it for friday night
these we have secured the top three
positions congratulations guys you have
win amazon vouchers
and the explanation for this guys flown
method in python returns the floor of x
that is the largest integer node greater
than x the method c
and in round brackets you can pass the
argument and in python it returns a
ceiling value of x that is the smallest
integer greater than or equal to x fab's
method returns the absolute value of a
number as a float absolute denotes a
non-negative number this removes the
negative sign of the value if it has any
so very well guys
those who put it correct and
congratulations the top three
leaderboard and i have an announcement
to make
so
here's a gentle reminder for those who
are interested in upskilling your python
programming skills
a great opportunity for you to get a
free course in python basics with a
completion certificate to enroll in the
course find the link in the description
box below you can check it out guys
and one more announcement if you aim
to get certified python programming
professional and want to build a python
software development career in that case
you can check the python certification
course by simple enough which will open
the doors for the best career
opportunities to find the details in the
python certification course
check the link in the description below
it would be the ideal solution to help
you build your career in the right
direction thank you for being a great
audience you meet again with a hearty
promise to return with another intro
service till then stay tuned with
simplyline
tata guys
and a gentle reminder topsy scorers can
send your screenshots to youtube contest
simplylearn.net and you can receive your
amazon volusions in some days
in the minimize days that is one or two
days okay guys thank you